stop turned into a gruesome scene when a
vehicle slammed into a crowd of people
were pausing the video because it's too
graphic and disturbing to fully show
horrific it was terrible people were
running to help them the bodies were all
over the place the victims were lined up
along the road outside the osnam
homeless shelter when the SUV struck
them around 8 30 a.m Witnesses say the
driver then tried to flee but was
detained by others at the scene there's
reports that are going out that he was
driving recklessly there's others saying
that he was intoxicated and there's
others saying that he was intentional
seven people died at the scene one died
at a nearby hospital and several others
remain in critical condition among the
dead Angel vay cavarka his cousin says
he came across the body seconds after
the crash
authorities say those victims include
Asylum Seekers from Latin America